oi bom dia não sei lá
eu quero falar sobre como usar o tempo
que teimoso teimoso agora o que fazer
escutar ele é muito
o porquê porque é preservar criança não
as crianças aprendem a sua língua sabem
já sabem pois é português porque o
cérebro aprendi aprendi muita
experiência ter tem experiência com
tenha não na língua vá poder fazer um
nós temos que fazer a mesma coisa é mas
temos que é desenvolver uma uma
estratégia de conteúdo escutar ele para
mim é muito importante eu quero uma
equilíbrio entre coisas simples que
podemos escutar o na outra vez muitas
vezes a mesma coisa para criar hábitos
no cérebro e coisas mais difícil de
equipe mais difíceis mais interessantes
mais difíceis para sempre estamos
escutando a mesma coisa
e o cérebro aprende - sim - porque o
cérebro precisa necessita a repetição
pela também necessita a novidade então
tem que fazer um equilíbrio para
praticar para crer novo hábitos na
língua temos que escutar muitas vezes
também o cérebro gosta mais difíceis
netflix coisas que podemos importar
olimpo por exemplo é nem temos as minha
história minha história então é eu
utilizo a as ministras sempre coma como
o exercício físico e como fazer
exercícios para o forno estômago
do pará pa fazer a ser mais forte para a
porta para poder acreditar em suas
capacidades na língua também temos que
buscar coisas novas como vocabulário
logo para acreditar na língua então as
coisas e se não entender tudo isso não
importa não importa é para dar ao
cérebro essa oportunidade essa
experiência como a língua e tom se você
tem essa é a experiência com a língua
nas explicações de gramática
o trem sentido e vocês não tem essa
experiência com a língua através vai
escutar escutar ele nas explicações de
gramática você não vai entender não vale
lembrar não valer nada então uma essa
período é
o canadá em brasília qualquer país que
não podemos ali ó
nós podemos praticar a língua lá
entendeu mas fica língua através da
escuta e lá a leitura leitura podemos
fazer simplesmente não é para falar
coisas que fazer trabalho café da manhã
uma capacidade agora vou
é uma sandalinha para importar conteúdo
aos da linda acredito pode ter muito
muito útil e
ah tá até até até logo mais
e aí
[Música]
g1
e aí